hello everyone I'm sudeesh I'm here to
present about a new API for high
performance access to data so the agenda
is we're going to talk about the mesh of
systems and applications they're
involved in providing analytics to end
users like you and how the data layout
is within each of these system and
applications and how across the systems
the communication happens right and
we're going to talk about one of those
communication api's which is ODBC and a
new one called arrow flight which is
what we've worked on extensively and I'm
going to show concrete numbers in the
demo all right on the high-level picture
on your on your right we have data
storage systems which is where the data
enters your business's infrastructure
right and on the Left we have
applications which is what the data
analyst use right and between we have
execution engines that provide algorithm
capability right they can run queries
they can they can interact with the
systems that are actually storing the
data and provide for example functions
that you can run in python right so so
the storage systems are where the day
enters your company's infrastructure and
the applications are what you're
interacting with so the data flows from
from the right to the left right and
your control messages flow from the left
to the right so when you ask for when
you run a query in python for example
the data the control messages go through
the execution engines to the data
storage systems and then the data flows
the other way around that's right
and there's no strict lines between the
types of systems and applications for
example python does execution as well
right and something like grêmio can
actually do both both provide an
application interface and and it is
actually it internally has an execution
engine built-in right and something like
redshift can actually store data and
provide execution
capabilities that is it provides equal
API the key thing to note is from the
time the data enters your company's
infrastructure to the time you consume
is what defines your time to insights
right so if you want insight into your
data if you have an ETL pipeline in
between well that's going to delay how
how quickly you can react to it in your
applications right and another thing
could be for example like how do I
discover all the day all the types of
data that's the company is collecting
right so now if it goes through some
cleansing and all of that then you do
not really have a picture of like all
the types of tables that you have access
to in your applications so the longer it
takes to gain insights into this kind of
data the longer it takes to actually
make it may not be worth it for example
right
if you've reacted very late to what the
what the information you're gathering is
so from an analyst point of view and
looking at data as tables I'm looking at
them as graphs I'm looking at them as
dashboards right as a storage point if
you I'm looking at data as how do I
store this more most efficiently for
access right as an execution engine
point of view how do i how do i for
example like make this use simply
instructions to make the processing go
faster right but if i'm looking at it
from a data engineer point of view right
it's gonna be how do i make these
pipelines more efficient so mike my
users can consume the data faster right
or if i'm looking at from data
administrator point of view how do i
access how do i restrict access to
different users based on their roles in
the company right or how do i provide
authentication and encryption
capabilities all right so as i said the
in this match the data goes from the
radio goes from right to left and
queries go from left to right right and
another way of thinking about this is
each component in this mesh has input
and output right for example s3's input
is files right someone's writing the
data to s3 and output is again really
api to those
files right for example for pandas the
data input is from various sources that
it can connect to and the output is data
frames for example something like drum
you actually can connect to any of these
storage systems and provide any of these
sources with an s3 redshift and
elasticsearch and it can provide REST
API JDBC API ODBC API and the new aro
API which is what I'm going to describe
alright so that was the quake pad which
is we are sending control messages
throughout the mesh of systems and now
let's talk about the data path right so
the data path first the data might not
be clean enough so there's going to be
people who are going to clean up that
dislike data engineers who work on those
pipelines and try to clean up the data
for easy consumption and the actual
algorithms you run through Python right
which is which is basically it could
just be sequel queries that you submit
to these databases right
and those sequel queries eventually get
converted to like filters and
aggregations right and how do those so
they live in different portions of that
right for example you could be doing
filtering and aggregations in Python you
could be doing it in execution engines
and some storage systems support that
like filtering at the scan level some
storage systems don't and so the further
you push logic towards where the data is
stored the the faster it's going to be
because the data flowing this way will
be lesser in size right smaller in size
so what are the other things that delay
the delay data transfer from left to
right right sorry right to left
for example there's network transfer
right so from one system to another if
they live on different horse well you
have to transfer the data from that to
this this is going to add to your time
time to insight right what else for
example if they don't speak the same
language for example like redshift
internally might represent data
differently than what Python represents
internally right so when redshift sends
data you have to serialize it over the
wire and then when Python reads it it
has to deesser eyes into a format
understand so it can manipulate the data
right so we have all these things that
are working against how fast you can get
insights into the data right and another
way of thinking about the same same
concept of like serialization
deserialization is you're making a copy
of the data right so you've read you
scan the files in s3 right and you've
converted it into a format that for
example drum you can understand and then
once you've given it to the client the
client is going to convert it again
right but every time you're making a
copy of the data right and that's very
expensive when we're talking about
kilobytes gigabytes it may not be that
expensive but once you go higher scale
it is going to be expensive because
you're going to make those copies every
time you transfer from one system to
another
right so people try to solve this
problem
for example redshift and dromio provide
an ODBC API that Python application can
consume right but the thing about ODBC
api is it defines it it was built in the
90 or 1990s which is older than me and
it provides an API to be able to connect
to the databases to prepare in prepare a
query I'm gonna run to execute to
actually execute the query and then to
fetch the results right so these this is
the API that it provided and it's and
it's mainly centered on how the clients
are going to consume it right it's not
centered on how the database is actually
implement how the database actually
manipulate the data and how they store
the data right
so it was built for something like
tables right you have rows rows of like
values and and they was built for
systems that were that were just single
instances running on one host they were
built for systems that have very few
cores that do not have very high
concurrency capabilities and clearly not
for analytical use cases because
analytical use cases do not rely on
records they mainly do computations on
columns right if I want to do analytical
queries for example I'm more about like
sums right which are like aggregations
Max's and mins not really look at this
person's name and then update the amount
of money they have in their bank right
so the solution to this is if all of
them spoke the same language in terms of
data right regardless of the initial so
the initial format in the storage could
be different right they could you have
CSV files you park a fallacy of Avro
files you have internal representations
within the system that there are
sometimes proprietary right so those
things the storage could be could be
less less efficient for actually running
the quote right
what I mean by that is well discs are
slow so once we there there will be
efficient representations of data on the
disk that is different from how the data
should be represented in memory or how
its represented on the wire right but
things in memory and on the wire by the
wire I mean network right they are
similar because well you've already read
the data so arrow tries to solve this
problem by providing exactly that
there's a lot of literature on on saying
that there is the columnar format for
analytical systems is much better than
row format like I said the simplest way
to think about this is if all the values
are next to each other you can easily
sum them up compared to doing random
scans on the disk right or in memory in
fact so
arrow is a set of libraries that
actually is used within various
in-memory analytical systems and the
biggest thing is once a system is done
with its work and it's relaying it on to
the next system we do not have to make
serialization deserialization if they
speak the same language which is the
language of the data in memory right and
it's built to work with modern hardware
in the sense that once you define the
format and if it's columnar you can use
simply instructions in all of that
so it is again one of the key things
it's language agnostic so C++ a system
written in C++ can talk to a system
written in Python or an application
written in Java for example right
alright so let's take this table as an
example traditionally if it were well
section ID times time source IP which is
which could be the data coming into your
system into your storage layer and now
if we layer if we represent it in how
ODBC expects the data to be well you
first do the first cell of the first row
and in the second cell of the first row
the third cell of the first row and so
on now obviously the alternative ways
first keep the first keep the first
column and then the second column and in
third column instead of row indeed
format right and imagine if you're doing
a min of the timestamps for example the
last time the user at or max right the
last time user accessed would be the
last of the timestamps and that'd be
easier to load in memory right versus
this which you would have to load the
first row and then figure out where that
value is versus just loading those four
values and that would be just be cash
efficient - all right and modern data's
also it comes in various formats it
comes in various shapes it comes in
various sizes and this is for example
JSON format and how would we represent
for example age next to each other well
you can just refer to the you have an
offset at least for let's look at for
example actually names right if the name
did not exist well you could just have a
null vector right what if the name did
exist you can put Joe and Jack next to
each other and then you can put you
could put the ages next to each other
and but then you would have to capture
how the schema is right so once we have
once we have a format like this which is
arrow memory buffer or a format like
this well we can actually build a lot of
libraries on top which is what
was you can build libraries to make
arbitrary expression compilation you can
build RPC libraries on top you can build
you can actually not very sure about
feather but you can do at the scan level
on the disks you can read park' files
directly into memory and you can have
efficient layers there too right so
given that record format in memory well
we can just put that on the wire as is
right you first write what the schema is
going to be well if you have compression
you also write the dictionary batch and
then you put all the records right after
that and on the other side the consumer
of this data already knows based on the
schema negotiation what the data looks
like and once the reader of the wire
well they don't have to deserialize
anything because it's already in the
language they understand the application
of the system understands next what do
we need on top well we need an RPC
framework on top and an api for that so
if someone says put this data you will
basically give them the header which
contains the schema and then you give
all the data and then you say I'm done
and the server is like ok and then if
you want the data you say ok this is the
data I'm looking for give me the give me
the data it first ascends you again the
header and then it sends all the record
batches right after that so this way
once this client or server read the data
they don't they don't do civilization or
die civilization because they already
understand the format all right and now
the key thing is well modern systems are
parallel right so you can provide a
flight which is the data that you're
looking for right so this is each of
this is a flight request and it's
composed of various streams right the
streams of data might live on different
hosts so we can provide a location right
and a ticket for that meaning I could it
could represent that you know you
actually have access to the data right
so when consuming application asks
the providing a system for example to
give me data it'll tell you here all the
hosts which you can scan data from and
here's all the streams that you can scan
the data from right and for example if
the host happened to be in the same data
center right the both the producer and
the consumer they happen to be in the
same data center well it also improves
the network grants because it won't be
that much delayed right versus going
across two data centers so you can have
one consumer for each of the streams and
you can basically if even if it's even
if it's providing n n streams I can
still consume them one after another
right or I can consume them all at once
if I have those many consumers side
stream those many stream consumers or if
you have fewer well you can throttle
those requests and whatnot all right so
now first we solved how the memories how
the data is going to look in each of
these systems right internally and then
we've solved how the data should be
transferred across these systems and
applications right and and well we can
even horizontally scale the streams
because each conceit stream end point
could be consumed by one specific
consumer as well alright time for the
demo
well in Python what does this mean I
have alright let me show you this setup
well so I'm running I'm running dreamy
look Jamie oh is a system that provides
a flight endpoint right any system that
implements that API could pro
technically provide a flat endpoint and
Romeo is one of those systems so what I
did is I have a JSON data set that
basically has a bunch of numbers I think
this is one of the TPC H or TP CPS data
sets and it's in JSON now I applied the
JSON format and this is ready for
consumption through any Python
application right
for example I can connect to a PI to PI
ODBC by ODBC application that opens a
connection to Dremel and then it
consumes it runs the sequel right and
then fetches all the results and after
that you have the data frame and you can
manipulate the data frame however you
want well similarly some people like
there is also something called turbo
ODBC which underneath the ODBC driver
uses Aero as a representation but again
there is the problem of converting it
into an API that the consumers can
understand which is ODBC right which is
the thing that is making it slow and
then this also is the same well you open
you open the connection you execute the
query and you fetch all the results
flight looks similar so this is just for
authentication so you can we can skip
that part right so you open you open a
flight client and you can authenticate
to it and then you're getting the data
and you can immediately convert it into
a data frame and you can do whatever
with it right so let's see let's first
run the PI ODBC application well this is
going to scan the JSON file
right into an in-memory representation
interim use case it is arrow so it is to
a there's a initial
scan time duration that you're actually
spending right and then it has to send
to the point a client application well
it shows a very simple query just a
select star right because well that
would still prove the point right
because you're doing a data transfer and
you're doing a serialization these
realize you know about that and then
drem you know sends the results via the
python api is it the PI ODBC
library and it's consumed on the other
side right so well that took 32 seconds
we will see what that means now let's
run through turbo turbo DBC application
fashion that does the same thing but its
internal representation now is arrow on
the client side right well this should
be faster because there's a lot of
optimizations that ran into just
building this library right but it's
still again at the end provides in ready
BC API so we have to do a copy convert
so clearly it's faster than then the
Python native one and now let's use the
flight app which basically just uses the
flight API and still at the end converts
to a data frame that an analyst ticket
will use and this should be faster all
right so let's actually break down what
each of these times mean so do all this
took 11 seconds of where is now the 11
seconds spent right so we can look at
for example profile for this and what it
shows is actually let's go to the first
one which is 32 seconds 31 seconds let's
see what it did for 31 seconds well it
shows that we had to scan the table
right we had to scan the JSON file it
took 11 seconds to scan that right but
then it was spending the remaining time
somewhere right so the remaining time is
actually spent in where did it go
blocked on downstream downstream is the
application and it was mainly spent in
converting the buffers into an ODBC
representation right and like I said
turbo so this is queries to graeme
mm-hmm so with Indra me all right so
dreamy oaken has an execution engine
built-in right so it can scan a JSON
file and provide a sequel API on top
right so yes I'm using the sequel API so
flight only provides how to deal flight
says give me data but it doesn't and but
it doesn't know what they what that data
represents right so for example you can
say give me data from this file now you
can just give a location and give you
that give you that file Isis or you can
give it a command and in this case the
command is a sequel query right and
endpoint on the other side which is on
the dreamiest side understands the
sequel command and it's able to run that
and provide the flight results right
exactly so this is on the client side
and this is on the host whichever is
running the queries right so as you can
see most of the time was spent waiting
on downstream downstream is typically if
we consider data flowing from in a river
upstream is where the data started which
is the storage systems and downstream as
the applications right so that's what
this little thing is and it spent 90
like almost 19 seconds in the
application right on the other hand we
have 17 seconds
which is what the turbo ODBC app took in
this case 2 will be faster but again
most of the time there you go most of
the time is spent
there's 11 plus 6 I guess is spent again
in the application right something like
flight well they've already all read the
application already knows what the data
looks like so there should be near
you should be no time in the application
itself right and all the 11 seconds were
actually spent scanning the JSON file
right reading from disk so you can
imagine this is a single threaded
application right you could have a
multi-threaded application that scans
all of these streams at the same time
say for example you had partitioned data
with with file per date and you want to
consume all of these at the same time in
your Python application I haven't worked
with multi-threaded applications in
Python but again you will you each of
those threads would consume a different
stream from each of those hosts
so back to this as long as most systems
adopt arrows representation of data
within their memory and how they
communicate with other systems this is
going to do great because we know
columnar analytics could benefit a lot
from from laying the data out in a
certain format right and there's
actually a lot of involvement within the
various communities to move to this
format and contribute to the various
libraries that you can build on top
including the including Gandiva which is
just-in-time compilation for any
expression on top of on top of a column
for example right and and when you lay
out the data right next to each other
well simply becomes much easier but
something like Java you can't use those
instructions so you would have to write
converters into C++ and use native code
to make the calls right all right
that's how I have there's more
information about this on the Apache
arrow community and more also about
dreamy Oh on these links questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this end point is on the system side
right so as soon as so you've submitted
a sequel query over the wire right and
the results are coming back in arrow
format and now there's there's actually
a Python library called pi arrow that
directly is able to provide you act once
you've read it read it off the wire into
the buffers this Python library
basically lets you access that directly
so there is no conversion after that
I see what you mean
so as you're consuming the stream you
realize that for example that you want
to seek to a different location right on
the server side I I wonder how the scape
would work I don't think there's the
support for that because it's just to
put and get API right to put and get
stream API but then it doesn't have a
support for like skip this much maybe I
can I can see the enhancement should not
be yeah show me that hard to implement
[Music]
so ideally you want fewer you want
conversions happening on the server side
right no there's more resources there
and all of that and in this specific
case if redshift adopted the in-memory
format to be aro then there is no
conversion after that right but if
redshift has its own internal format
then it would have to convert to the aro
API to be able to provide this endpoint
that the client applications can use
[Music]
for sure I think there are more systems
that are adopting the format because
they see complete value in rep making
data the API right like if the client
and server understand how the data is
laid out well you don't need to change
anything about it don't need to copy
serialize deserialize and all of that
right so there are many other systems
that are adopting so this relies on
engineers everywhere to realize that
this is the way to go forward right and
it's not just arrow does not just come
with the layout right this it's not just
a specification it comes with all the
libraries on top that you can use to
build your systems right so and those
libraries are what people contribute to
in fact there's libraries for even I
think Nvidia processors that I don't
know if I have anything about that here
but I think even a new media has a team
that's working on how do we make
specifically like Aero computations
faster
so okay so arrow flight itself is built
on G RPC which provides which is built
on top of HTTP two as the API so you
don't have to technically use the data
layout as is you could still convert it
into messages that that can be used or
by any application right so at that
point you're converting it into you
still have a conversion from from what's
in memory into a protobuf message for
example the clients can understand but
if they can use so that you don't have
to what you provided here or used to
need to do some sort of
[Music]
you know conversion between if you want
to so at that point I think the library
natively supports converting to protobuf
so instead of running command and trying
to get it as as a stream you can get
them as messages and on top of that I
think you can actually build within the
library that's not there JSON support
right so it even though it's a protobuf
message you can easily quickly convert
it to a JSON and expose it to the
application good question I think it it
probably happened on the client mmm that
the serialization yes good question so
we do use that internally but there is
no library on top to provide it as a
public API yes it's almost like parking
exactly right but it's still I don't
think in in so there is converters from
Park a to arrow and park a is a more
popular format in terms of storing
columnar data so that made more sense
for most community users to add as a
library than just storing an arrow but
there's no reason to not store arrow in
memory or in disk
it's maybe more the the things that are
writing to storage systems have not
adopted that yes exactly so once you
have columnar representation it's
actually very highly compressed because
all numbers are together and there's
repetitions there so that is exactly
what the dictionary patch provides so
you can first negotiate the schema you
can provide a dictionary of all the
values and then the record matches now
your data is even smaller than what it
should have been yes it's baked into the
specification and it's also built in
quite a few I think it's yeah I think
it's built in most bindings in fact I
think well if the client doesn't support
dictionary batch as a thing the server
can do they can negotiate and say server
you send me only record batches I don't
understand compression
more questions
alright that's it for me then
[Applause]